غير عشرات الالاف الارواح والاصابات
الزلزال كمان دمر مئات الالاف من الابنيه
في كل من سوريا وتركيا ورغم انه قوه
الزلزال كانت مدمره وعاليه جدا لكن في
كثير لوم وانتقادات على اسلوب البناء وعلى
المتعهدين والمقاولين خاصه المسؤولين عن
المباني الجديده واللي ما صمدت في وجه
الزلزال اطلاقا وطريقه انهياره كانت يعني
مثل كانها من خشب يعني وفي هذا الخصوص
السلطات التركيه يبدو بدات جهودا في
محاسبه هؤلاء وكشفت اليوم انها قبضت على
مقاول في غازي عنتاب و 11 مقاول في شانلي
اورفا وهذولا مسؤولين عن بنايات اتهدمت
بالكامل مو بس كده كشفت السلطات التركيه
كمان انه واحد من هدولا كان متعهد تجمع
سكني فيها طيب وتدمر بشكل كامل في الزلزال
وتخيلوا فيرميسكو في المطار جالس بيحاول
يهرب وشايل معاه مبالغ ماليه طائله
وعلى الرغم من انه في ابنيه انهارت بشكل
كامل في ابنه فضلت صامده وما صابها شيء
مثل مبنى المهندسين المدنيين في قهرمان
مرعش اللي كانت من مراكز الزلزال هذا
المبنى اللي تم تداول صور له وسط الحطام
بعد الزلزال وما صار في اي ضرر حتى الزجاج
ما انكسر والناس صارت تتوقع انه هل هذا يا
ترى بناءه بمعايير هندسيه عاليه ومقاومه
للزلازل ولا ايش هل لانه مبنى مخصص
للمهندسين يعني فرحوا بضمير يعني كيف نرجع
من الانهيار وحتى الزجاجه ما تكسر لكن رجع
ناس كمان تداول وصور ابعد شويه وقالوا مو
صحيح انه المبنى الوحيد اللي صمد وانه في
غيره كمان على فكره صمدوا ومن الحديث عن
انعدام ضمير متعهدين ومقاولين بيسترخص
وكانوا في البناء وسببوا كل هذه الخسائر
بسبب طمعهم شفنا نوع ثاني من الطمع اعجب
واعجب وسرنا نسمع قصص عن سرقه مساعدات
للمتضررين من الزلزال فشفنا مثلا فيديو
الاعتقال السلطات التركيه لشخص كان يدعي
انه مشرف على مساعدات دوليه وبياخذ
المساعدات ويحطها في مستودعات ويبيعها
للناس في سوريا برضو سمعنا وشفنا قصص عن
سرقه مساعدات غير سرقه المساعدات كمان في
ناس وسط كل هذا الدمار جالسين ينهبوا في
البيوت والمتاجر المدمره هذول اعلنت
التركيه عن القبض على ثمانيه واربعين منهم
في ثمانيه محافظات وتوعدت بملاحقه
الباقيين ايضا
[موسيقى]